[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
16 septembre bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une mission pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
voici les titres le modem 78 envisagent
de partir seul pour les élections
législatives de l'an prochain le parti
de françois bayrou souhaite investir ces
candidats si alain juppé ne remporte pas
la primaire de la droite et du centre
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
poursuivent leur rapprochement pour une
éventuelle fusion les deux départements
viennent de donner naissance à site
alios un nouvel acteur de l'aménagement
urbain en ile de france nous recevrons
son directeur général sur ce plateau et
puis dans cette émission nous
reviendrons sur le reste de l'actualité
avec notamment françois hollande en
déplacement à saint quentin en yvelines
pour parler formation ou encore la
société du grand paris qui accélère sur
les différents chantiers des futurs
métro mais je vous le disais dans les
titres le mouvement démocrate 60,18
faisait sa rentrée hier à versailles une
rentrée placée sous le signe des
échéances électorales à venir et le
parti centriste menace si alain juppé ne
remporte pas la primaire de la droite il
présentera ses propres candidats pour
les législatives
les précisions de florane parfait
le message est clair pour le modem c'est
juppé ou rien le parti centriste soutien
d'anciens premiers ministres pour la
primaire de la droite question de
valeurs question d'idées ou encore
d'amitié le seul qui se soit déclaré
ouvertement pour un large rassemblement
oui vous appelle ça progressiste et pour
ça la large rassemblement humaniste et
porteurs d'idées nouvelles
porteur de témoins vers une politique
autrement le seul qui l'ait fait c'est
alain juppé et ça correspond exactement
à tous qu'on prône depuis dix ans déjà
donc
naturellement qu'on va vers lui les
autres n'ont rien montré de tel donc
effectivement vers alain juppé et en
plus vous connaissez les
liens d'amitié qui le lie à à françois
bayrou d'amitié de respect et si le
maire de bordeaux ne remporte pas la
primaire au mois de novembre
le modem soit 118 menace est présente
déjà une liste de candidats pour les
élections législatives de l'an prochain
avec 12 binôme qui défendront leur
valeur c'est un risque mais si on ne
prend pas de toute façon on n'existera
jamais donc quelque part vous avez vu
que nous avons une vision
humaniste et nous voulons la développer
et c'est en
parlant en agissant au quotidien que
nous allons vendre nos idées que les
gens vont petit à petit il y adhérer moi
j'y crois et c'est pour ça que je
m'engage parmi les autres candidats prix
investi georges believe sur la 10e
circonscription la primaire de la droite
et du centre se tiendra les 20 et 27
novembre prochains huit candidats sont
en lice et alain juppé reste le favori
qui selon les sondages
est pour évoquer à présent l'actualité
de la semaine avait été un invité nous a
rejoint sur le plateau hervé gay bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur général
de sita llosa un nouvel établissement
public né il y a quelques jours et fruit
du rapprochement entre le département
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine alors
franchement voulu par les deux
présidents des conseils départementaux
est entamée déjà il y a plusieurs mois
hervé gay est ce que pour commencer vous
pouvez déjà nous expliquer concrètement
ce qui est site alios ses champs
d'action ses missions et ses objectifs
alors si tu as you c'est une société qui
travaille pour le compte des
collectivités locales pour mettre en
oeuvre leurs projets urbains des petits
projets ou des grands projets petits
projets d'équipements publics grand
projet de réaménagement de quartier donc
nous travaillons pour leur compte dans
un souci d'équilibré économique bien sûr
nous rachetons des terrains où les
réaménagements ils céderont promoteurs
pour qu'ils réalisent les les
constructions dont les villes ont besoin
et nous surveillons l'ensemble des des
chantiers nous les corps de nom et pour
remettre clé en main en quelque sorte un
nouveau quartier aux élus de la manière
où l'on imaginé et si tallio ceci si je
me trompe pas c'est le regroupement de
quatre anciennes société mixte
d'aménagement d'économie mixte
d'aménagement c'est au ruban de quatre
sociétés qui existait deux qui
travaillaient sur le territoire des
yvelines 2 du territoire des hauts de
seine quel est l'intérêt de se regrouper
comme ça à 4 quel est l'avantagé on est
plus puissant financièrement sont ou
alors on est plus puissant
financièrement on est aussi plus
puissant en termes de compétences
puisque chaque société avait son
histoire ses traditions ses spécificités
et donc en se regroupant nous sommes
aujourd'hui 94 salariés dans cette
entreprise site alios nous avons un
champ
d'intervention beaucoup plus large pour
répondre
très de manière très pointue à toutes
les questions qui nous sont peser sur le
champ urbain à chaque fois ce sont les
élus locaux qui viennent vous voir et
qui vous disent voilà je veux rien
enlever tell tale tel terrain j'ai
besoin d aide voilà c'est ça ils ont
besoin de compétences et nous apportons
ses compétences alors votre champ
d'action vous le disiez c'est yvelines
hauts de seine où ça va au delà alors ça
va au delà puisque nous sommes certains
statuts le capitaux capitaux
principalement public nous sommes une
société de droit privé donc nous
intervenons dans un champ concurrentiel
et depuis de longues années plusieurs
des sociétés qui composent si tu as lu
ow sz ont rayonné au delà de leur
territoire d'origine si tu as lu hausse
est aujourd'hui présent sur les huit
départements d'île de france alors dans
les présentations qui sont faites de
sita news on entend et on lit dans la
presse notamment une structure plus
souple plus et flea plus efficiente plus
complète ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ça en quoi le fait d'être
réunis vous êtes meilleur que quand vous
étiez 4 divisé et puis notamment plus
souplesse que d'être une grosse
structure c'est pas ce qu'on reproche
généralement une grosse machine qui a du
mal à se mettre en route et qui peut
parfois être assez loin du petit élu
local voilà alors c'est effectivement
l'écueil dans lequel il ne faut pas
tomber
94 salariés ça reste une entreprise de
taille humaine
le contact entre la direction générale
et les salariés de base je dirais son
son quotidien reste quotidien donc nous
avons beaucoup réfléchi sur la
l'organisation à mettre en a mais tu
remplaces et nous avons donc une
organisation par métier et chaque mais
chaque métier a un patron mais le
responsable d'un projet
mon contact quotidien comme vous dites
avec le petit élu local il n'y a pas de
petit nom que des grands y'a que des
grands et les bien sûr il ya des élus et
voilà ils ont tous leur légitimité donc
le chef de projet qui ont contacts
quotidiens pour mener à bien le projet
de l'élu il n'a qu'un niveau
hiérarchique entre lui et le directeur
général donc ça c'est de la souplesse ça
c'est de la réactivité
c'est ce que nous voulons apporter à nos
clients alors on imagine évidemment que
vous allez faire vous allez faire des
logements vous allez faire construire et
bâtir uniquement des logements alors
uniquement des logements c'est plus dans
l'air du temps passé notre conception de
la ville faire des quartiers entièrement
de logements s'est pas c'est pas durable
c'est des quartiers qui perdent de leur
de leur amour condamné il ya rien il
suffit de regarder les grands ensembles
les grandes ensemble c'était quoi dans
les années 60 c'était des quartiers de
logements uniquement de logements et ça
a donné les conséquences que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui une ville doit être
mixtes vous devez avoir du logement mais
aussi des commerces des commerces de
proximité des activités
publiques comme des théâtres et salles
de des salles de sport des bureaux
lorsqu'on est situé au pied des
transports une ville elle doit vivre
toute la journée tous les jours de la
semaine il faut donc mixer les fonctions
ce qui veut dire qu'un au sein d'un
établissement comme le vôtre les métiers
se sont diversifiées bien sûre
diversifiée se diversifient tout le
temps parce que une crise économique y
arrive ce qui fait que les meules de
modèle économique d'hier n'est plus
celui d'aujourd'hui et nous devons être
réactifs et nous avons un important
programme de formation de nos
collaborateurs est ce que vous êtes né
précisément le 7 septembre dernier ce
que vous avez déjà des projets dans les
cartons notamment pour les yvelines et
pour saint quentin alors des projets on
en a et on travaille avec avec des
mairies dans l'espoir qu'il puisse du
confié nous confier de
nouvelles missions sita llosa gagner le
lendemain de sa création un projet c'est
un peu symbolique puisque en fait
c'était une des quatre sociétés qui
avaient candidaté nous avait réintégré
les projets récupère aux anciennes
sociétés anciennes sociétés
nous avons dans les yvelines nous sommes
très près évidemment très présent dans
les yvelines je peux vous donner
quelques exemples d'actualité puisque
mardi prochain nous livrons les premiers
logements
d'une opération d'aménagement à
rocquencourt
qui avait été suivie par un de nos
de l'une de nos sociétés yvelines
aménagements
demain samedi l'inauguration de la
maison du projet à poissy sur le
quartier rouget de lisle au pied de la
station de train de poissy beaucoup de
projets en voilà nous sommes présents
également au bureau sur les grands
projets de renouvellement urbain des des
mureaux depuis plusieurs années c'est
des projets qui avancent qu'ils se qui
se poursuivent dans le reste de
l'actualité cette semaine françois
hollande était en déplacement à saint
quentin en yvelines il a visité les
locaux dit fuck up l'institut de
formation commerciale permanente
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état et
d'évoquer la mise en place du plan
gouvernemental 500000 formation
supplémentaire est l'occasion pour nous
aussi de vous faire découvrir l'institut
reportage
250 stagiaires formés l'an passé
cinquante intervenants pour une
quinzaine de formations métiers le
nouveau centre ifo coop est implantée à
montigny le bretonneux depuis septembre
2015 avec pour objectif un retour à
l'emploi rapide et pour y parvenir une
seule formule magique 50% du temps en
entreprise 50% en formation le format
des formations ifo cops et quatre mois
en centre de formation est une
application concrète de quatre mois en
entreprise ça fait partie du cursus de
chercher et de trouver son entreprise
nous l'objectif ce n'est pas une
formation pour un stage c'est une
formation pour un
fois web digital gestion ressources
humaines ou encore comptabilité le choix
de formation est conséquent à saint
quentin en yvelines et répond aux
besoins des entreprises locales peu
importe l'âge ou les diplômes le plus
important se trouve ailleurs pour les
intéressés les plus jeunes auront 21 22
ans il est indispensable pour entrer à
l'ifop d'avoir au moins un an
d'expérience professionnelle ça c'est
vraiment le préalable indispensable pour
tout le monde sur certains métiers on va
demander une expérience professionnelle
ou non au préalable sur d'hôtel pour
être plus courte mais peut être
compensée par un niveau bac un niveau
bac +2 en fonction des qualifications
requises a vécu à l'issue de la
formation
skil récurrent chez toutes les personnes
encore une fois c'est vraiment la
motivation la détermination le projet
professionnel et l'adéquation avec le
marché du travail bien sûr en l'espace
d'un an plus de 200 inscrits à l'ifocop
de saint quentin en yvelines ont
retrouvé un emploi un chiffre qui
pourrait être amplifiée avec le plan
500000 formations supplémentaires mises
en place par le gouvernement
l'actualité c'est également la semaine
de la mobilité qui a débuté à saint
quentin en yvelines au programme
animations dans les entreprises et
enquête sur le réseau stibus mais aussi
un jeu la chasse aux bus avec cinq
véhicules qui ont fait peau neuve en
arborant les nouvelles couleurs de sky
l'objectif trouver ces bus ouvrir l'oeil
et les attraper en images on écoute à ce
propos michel laugier le président de
saint quentin en yvelines il nous en dit
un peu plus sur cette semaine de la
mobilité
douce ou eto'o à travers cette semaine
bien que proposer à tous les usagers un
petit peu
les services qui sont apportées tout au
long de l'année par l'agglomération et
puis surtout à mettre à l'eau d'heure
bien sûr tous ceux qui travaillent
tomber des moyens pour que justement et
puis se prendre quelques quelques
minutes et bien comprendre aujourd'hui
toutes les possibilités qui leur sont
offertes pour participer à cette chasse
aux bus vous avez jusqu'au 15 octobre
retrouvez toutes les modalités
d'inscription du jeu sur sky1 point fr
on referme cette page transports et
déplacements avec la société du grand
paris qui faisait sa rentrée cette
semaine l'établissement public a
présenté l'état d'avancement des
différents chantiers des futures lignes
de métro après la phase de concertation
place au début des travaux
c'est une étape de plus pour le métro du
grand paris express les premiers travaux
ont commencé sur plusieurs tronçons
franciliens c'est le cas notamment pour
les futures lignes à 15 et 16 pour la
ligne 18 en revanche qui desservira
saint quentin en yvelines les études
techniques sont encore en cours
à ce stade là il n'y a pas de retard
puisque on en était vraiment aux études
préliminaires maintenant le maître
d'oeuvre a été désigné et donc il va
travailler sur les études d'avant projet
et c'est à ce niveau des études d'avant
projet qu'on fixe définitivement le
tracé de la ligne est la position des
gardes à terme la ligne 18 du grand
paris express reliera l'aéroport d'orly
à versailles coût du projet estimé à un
peu moins de 3 milliards d'euros pour
une mise en service totale en 2030 d'ici
là plusieurs projets pensés par des
étudiants franciliens verront le jour
l'un d'entre eux doit favoriser les
échanges entre riverains commerçants et
entreprises avec comme espace d'accueil
des containers ça sera vraiment c'est
l'impact visuel qu'on veut d'abord à
voir donc avec le conteneur sera
vraiment la forme à de la tôle quoi avec
une terrasse qu'on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de voir sur un container et
l'intérieur par contre sera vraiment
aménagé pour par exemple pour la
restauration avec vraiment les
réfrigérateurs le plan de travail donc
l'intérieur sera vraiment nous on
pourrait concerner des utilisateurs et
consommateurs devront en tout cas se
montrer patient les premières rames de
métro dans les yvelines n'arriveront pas
avant 14 ans
hervé gay on a présenté site adios tout
à l'heure on a évoqué ses champs
d'action d'action est ce que est ce que
le vous intéressait également au terrain
qui vont être autour des gares du grand
paris on sait que c'est un grand projet
et y'a rien que du côté de saint quentin
et sur la ligne 18 9 nouvelles gares qui
vont être construites avec des logements
forcément autour est ce que ce sont des
projets qui vous intéressent vous bien
sûr c'est potentiel de développement un
potentiel d'attractivité pour les villes
ces gars c'est une chance exceptionnelle
donc nous sommes d'ores et déjà
d'ailleurs présents autour des futures
gares du grand paris alors pas dans les
yvelines mais dans les hauts-de-seine
asnières sur seine par exemple autour de
la future station les grésillons nous
avons un très gros projet d'écoquartier
de 200 mille mètres carrés environ de
logements de bureaux de commerces à
réaliser au pied de cette future gare du
grand paris sur les yvelines nous
intéressons à toutes les gares nous
intéressons aux gars de la future ligne
est elle aussi qui va relier la gare
saint lazare à paris et puis à nantes
pardon et puis pourquoi pas à 50,1 des
gars de cette fameuse ligne 18
guyancourt nous sommes tous prêts à
travailler pour les élus sur ces sujets
vous avez évoqué au début de l'émission
delà de la concurrence quelle est votre
concurrent sur ces qui est votre
concurrent sur ces dossiers là c'est
grand paris aménagements grand parce que
si tu as llosa aussi été construit pour
vous va dire un peu bloqué le grand
paris pourront pas se faire avaler par
le par le grand paris et toutes les
machines qui toutes les institutions qui
gravitent autour du de la métropole du
grand paris le site a dios a bien sûr
une essence politique donc c'est cette
idée que vous développez existe existe
que pierre bédier patrick devedjian ne
sont pas les plus grands fans de cette
idée du grand paris c'est pour ça que je
vous dis ça aussi audacieux
nous avons été aussi créé pour offrir
des alternatives
aux élus avec une vision de travail en
étroite collaboration avec les élus nous
sommes pas justement pas une grande
machine administrative
nous sommes une société réactif comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure avec des élus à
notre conseil d'administration donc nous
écoutons les élus nous parlons leur
langage nous savons traduire leurs idées
en fait quel est le retour des élus pour
l'instant sur site à lui aussi vous
sollicite ils vous disent tant mieux que
vous soyez là quels sont les premiers
apple c'est c'est une très grande
comment dire appétence pour pour cette
société
là vous l'avez volonté de voir les les
bons les bons projets que nous avons
réalisés enfin que chacune de nos quatre
sociétés ont réalisé par le passé les
voies retranscrire sur leur territoire
vous êtes mine de rien quand même une
grosse structure certes moins grosse que
celle du grand paris aménagement est ce
que c'était nécessaire de vous
rassembler aujourd'hui pour survivre on
peut pas être une société d'économie
mixte d'aménagement seul il faut quand
même peser un certain poids faut il faut
un certain poids tout à fait c'est
nécessaire aujourd'hui on a un monde qui
évolue deux très vite la crise
économique de 2008 a été dure pour les
sociétés
de ce type surtout pour les plus petites
nous nous avons survécu parce que nous
avions un poids suffisant et nous savons
que dans ce monde incertain on a besoin
de solidité on change de sujet à présent
avec l'université de versailles saint
quentin qui a fait son retour dans le
prestigieux classement de shanghai un
retour après cinq ans d'absence wilfrid
richie recevait d'ailleurs le nouveau
président de l'université didier
guillemot pour évoquer ce sujet écoute
et l'université de versailles saint
quentin a retrouvé sa place parmi le
classement de shanghai la dernière fois
c'était en 2011 la première fois c'était
en 2011 c'est entre la 400e et la 500e
place c'est ça à peu près que vous se
situe votre établissement au niveau
international absolument c'est même
probablement plus près de là 430e c'est
à dire plus près de la 400e que de la
60e et c'est vraiment une très bonne
nouvelle c'est quoi ce classement
concrètement alors c'est le classement
de shanghai c'est un déclassement de
référence pour classer les universités
du monde je crois qu'il ya dix sept
mille universités dans le monde quelque
chose comme ça il se trouve que il ya ce
classement qui est organisé par
l'université de shanghai et qui les
classe principalement sur la visibilité
et la notoriété scientifique
et donc le classement de shanghai s'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga c'est simplement
un classement sur une échelle et bon
voila quand je suis arrivé aux
responsabilités j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
réponde de façon le plus professionnel
possible et le 15 août les résultats
sion qui vous voyez retrouver ce
placement puisque l'université elle
allait quitter un temps oui je voulais
retrouver dire que je voulais savoir où
on en était c'est à dire que je voulais
faire un bilan comme je souhaite faire
un bilan financier un bilan des
activités notre université et ça fait
partie du bilan et je me disais que si
on était 499e c'était mieux que si nous
étions 500 lignes m il se trouve que le
classement est plutôt extrêmement bons
et que nous sommes revenus comme vous
l'avez dit au classement de shanghai
c'est à dire en gros parmi les 22
premières universités françaises sur la
dimension classement shanghai et les
étudiants de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin également dans
l'actualité puisqu'il se sont mobilisés
eux cette semaine contre la loi travail
avec une nouvelle et peut être dernière
journée de mobilisation qui avait lieu
jeudi 15 septembre l'unef le syndicat
étudiant a participé d'ailleurs à la
manifestation parisienne écoutez le
président local du syndicat il était au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
aujourd'hui on part en direction de
paris pour rejoindre la manifestation
contre la loi travail en effet même si
la loi travail est passée elle reste
toujours aussi n'accepta bhl est
toujours aussi exécrable pour notre
avenir et qu'on va manifester
aujourd'hui aux côtés des lycéens et des
salariés cette loi dans son ensemble est
inacceptable elle fait qu'augmenter la
précarité au travail du coup on continue
à se mobiliser pour le retrait lavaud
travail dans son entièreté mais on
demande aussi l'ouverture des
discussions parce que des propositions
on en a des propositions pour améliorer
la réussite des jeunes pour diminuer le
chômage etc ce tarif tard on en a il
faudra conduire le retrait la loi
travail et l'ouverture de discussions
pour de vraies mesures dans ce sens du
progrès social on referme ce 7,8 hebdo
en culture avec ce week-end les journées
du patrimoine le thème cette année
concernent notamment la citoyenneté à 17
milles lieux seront ouverts partout en
france et à saint quentin en yvelines on
n'est pas en reste non plus de la
commanderie des templiers à elancourt
aux hôtels de ville de guyancourt et
rappelé au programme est chargé tout le
week-end petit tour d'horizon avec
mélanie poker
des salles de spectacles des espaces de
recherche ou encore des mairies les
lieux saint quentinois répondent
présents pour les journées européennes
du patrimoine
à plaisir la clé des champs et le
théâtre espace coluche feront découvrir
l'envers du décor j'aurais moyen de
montrer au public dépeindre la salle
d'allumer le plateau ce qu'on appelle en
plein feu pour qu'il se rende compte que
quand on a tous ces projecteurs dans la
figure on ne voit plus le public on ne
fait que le ressentir thème de la
citoyenneté oblige des ouvertures
exceptionnelles
les hôtels de ville de trappes et
guyancourt organise des visites guidées
à elancourt la commanderie des templiers
ouvre elle aussi ses portes l'occasion
de pénétrer dans la chapelle a rarement
ouverte au public la construction a été
commencée en fin du xiième siècle et
c'est une chapelle donc du xiiie siècle
ce qui est intéressant ici c'est de la
revoir après réouverture donc à l'arrêt
ouvert en 2012 après restauration et
vous pourrez découvrir la restauration
qui a été fait à savoir la peinture les
peintures murales
voilà il est vitraux qui ont été
nettoyées à deux pas de saint quentin en
yvelines à saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse la
fondation martha panne vous replonge
dans l'atelier et les oeuvres de la
sculptrice d'origine hongroise elle a
sculpté ici ses premières oeuvres
parfois de très grande dimension je
pense notamment aux sculptures dont
maurice béjart s'est emparé pour faire
pour créer deux ballets
et puis là effectivement travaillé
pendant une dizaine d'années ici à
travailler le bois à ce moment là à
découvrir aussi le domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles le théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines le
centre national du cinéma et de l'image
animée à bois d'arcy et bien d'autres
lieux encore le patrimoine vous tend les
bras
c'est la fin de ce set 8 hebdo merci à
hervé gaidoz de nous avoir accompagnés
pendant cette demi heure je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur général de sita
llose merci à vous aussi de nous avoir
suivis bon week-end à tous
[Musique]